(cheering)
Hi, how are you my love?
When Manny and I first met, he was like,
you really like me, don't you?
And I was like no I did
I really did.
I do
I'm like, you like me the best don't you?
Yeah, I felt such a deep connection with you.
It was like magnetic.
And we went on this great trip together.
We went on this whole weekend, doing all things beauty.
And--
And so much fun.
we really, we just, we fit together
like a little--
We did
Puzzle piece as soon as we met.
Yeah, Well, you're such a wonderful person
Manny and so talented.
When did you first fall in love with makeup?
You know for me I feel
like my makeup journey really started when I was a
we taught, if you will, I would watch my mom glam,
in the morning she would
before she would go to work, she'd be climbing
in her beauty room essentially, which is her room.
And I would just watch her get ready.
And it was so much fun for me.
And that's kind of where I found
like the love of my beauty space in the beginning.
And I registered a number of really, really
really loving that idea of a similar
being able to help someone transform
to whatever they want it to be.
So I wanted to be able to help people feel their best.
And that's exactly what I wanted to do.
Now, let's talk about lunar beauty and you've had this
for a while.
It's so beautiful.
This new pallet, by the way, my new favorite color
is the earth bender because I'm such a fan
of a Brown smokey eye.
And this is a Brown with this incredible OBOR Jean tent.
Really great for the green pupils here.
I mean, look at this componentry too.
You have this really exquisite diamond coming up
in the middle of like this thick, beautiful sort of acrylic.
And then it's on braid and just, I'm sorry
but that's a color.
Every woman wants to wear.
Every man--
Thank you.
Is wearing on your lips Manny?
I'm waiting Aura,
actually shared that you just pulled out.
Well, that's a perfect segue
because we wanted to play a little game with you
called eye spy
(graphic thud)
where we can show you a closeup
of a celebrity person of notes, eye makeup
and you have to try to identify who it is.
Plus, most importantly, if we can get them Manny
MUA tip on maybe how to achieve such eye--
Absolutely, I got you.
I got you I am a game player
Me too in all the right ways.
(laughs)
I knew what you meant okay--
Play let's play it in a good way.
Yeah, exactly, all right.
The first photo.
I'm gonna guess see for me
I think this is' Nicki Minaj
I could be wrong.
(bell rings)
Let's see.
Oh, it's perfect.
You did brilliantly now any tip on this eye,
This kind of look, it's honestly a super easy look.
What I would just say, just do primer on the eyes
and just add a little bit of shadow in the beginning.
Part on braid into the outer portion.
It's actually really not hard looking cheap.
I know it looks kind of scary, but it really isn't.
It's literally a multi-tonal look with lashes on super easy
but it looks a little intense.
Okay, put up the second photo please.
And who do you think Manny?
Honestly, I really don't know.
They have a little bit of a hooded lid.
Well, should we reveal?
Let's reveal I don't know.
Let's reveal.
It's quite so funny.
What a stunning vision that she is.
I know you said something really interesting,
a hooded lid.
How does one do a better eye makeup around a hooded eye?
So what I'd like to do, so with hooded lids
but obviously like what it means
like the skin here falls over a little bit onto your eyelid
so you don't get as much eyelid space.
I actually have a hooded lid myself, as you can see, my
lid is right here
but it kind of ends right there because the skin falls over.
So what I like to do is I kind of like just the teeth
the system I'll put the shouts into the socket
of my eye and not just the skin to make it look
like I have more space than I really do.
So that's just a really easy, simple trick.
Just kind of go a little bit higher
than what you think you would need to go
into the socket line and just kind of carve
into where you would just want to create your crease.
Oh, I love that, okay last photo.
Whoa.
Okay, you know what I think
I feel like this is Billy Porter.
(bell rings)
(cheering)
And you have, like, I remember seeing gorgeous golden
beautiful moment from him.
Now what's the sort of more wearable version
of this Manny cause I love this look.
Absolutely, So for me what I would do for more where
my version, I would just do like a soft gold on the lid
something easy, a little golden, the lid moment.
And then adding like maybe one or two little gold
rhinestones without there on the outer corner out here or
on the Brown bowl.
And really just vamps up that look
and just gives you a little pop of something
without being too aggressive.
I'm literally going to go get some jewels for my eyes.
Honestly, they are so fun.
I love a little jewel moment.
All right you sure, to check out Manny's line lunar beauty
which everybody already loves and knows
and has been really out there
for a long time and just Marvel
at the quality and the authority that is Manny MUA.
Thank you Manny so much.
Thank you of course.
(applause)
Oh my gosh and by the way,
this packaging, it's just so amazing.
And you can go to our website and we'll link you right there
and have a little page about,
lunar beauty as well.
But thank you so much.
And Manny, thank you.
(upbeat music)